- Welcome to the developer show.
My name is Filip Hiracek,
and I'm here with Tim Sneath.
Hi, Tim.
Hi, Filip.
- So, who are you?
And what are you
doing in the team?
- I'm Tim Sneath, and
I'm the group product
manager for Flutter and
for Dart here at Google.
- Tim, you joined the
team quite recently.
What are your first
impressions of Flutter?
- Yeah, so I joined the team
about, what, nine weeks ago
now.
I came from Microsoft,
where I'd been there
for 17 years,
something like that,
and I came to Google because I
was really inspired by Flutter.
It's just such a
beautiful platform.
It feels productive.
It's efficient.
It's a great way to build
mobile applications,
whether you're targeting
iOS or Android.
- I also know you recently
spent some time with "Hamilton"
in New York.
What can you tell us about that?
- Yeah, yeah.
So not Hamilton himself, right?
Obviously he's long dead.
But we went to New York to
film a case study video of one
of the first applications
that's been built with Flutter,
and that is the "Hamilton"
musical official app.
And they wanted
to build this app
to be able to connect more
closely with their fans,
and so they were looking
around for a platform,
a framework they
could move quickly,
they could iterate fast, and
they could chip something
simultaneously both for
iOS and for Android,
and they picked Flutter.
They had a really good time
and they talked a little bit
about it in this video, and
some of their experiences
using Flutter, and they
are fully converted
to Flutter as a technology now.
- So Tim, what are you excited
about for Flutter in 2018?
- Yeah, so we really think
this is the year of Flutter.
We hope it's the
year of Flutter.
It's the year
where a lot of work
the the team has been working
on for several years now
comes to fruition.
We're at the point
now where Flutter
is about to go into
beta, and this year we're
going to continue to build
on the foundations we've
laid with Flutter.
We're going to add things
like ads and map views
and inline video.
We want to just
continue to build out
the richness of the experience.
We've also announced
it's Dart conf this week,
Dart 2, which is a reboot
of the language for client
development, and we're starting
to turn that on within Flutter
as well, so that's going to
be another thing you're going
to see over the next
couple of months in the run
up to Google I/O, which is of
course the next big developer
conference.
- Thank you, Tim, and
thank you audience.
This has been the developer
show from Dart conf in L.A.